[音楽]
60歳デー
評者孫止めサラリーマン生活をすっぱりとやめてこのアジア教育友好協会
i ハを立ち上げました
まあ私の人生は新しい人生を踏み出して今や
東奔西走本葬熟年です
肉体的にもしやる気もねまだ青年だと思ってですがちょっとここ
薄くなりましたけど
アジアの山奥で
主として山岳の票数民族のために学校建設をしてきています
そして蛍雪を今度は日本の子どもたちと国際交流をやってきました
これが作り上げた学校の一例です
[拍手]
動く150個
まあそれなりの活動してきましたね
でもそもそもなんで私が
山岳少数民族というものに目を向けたかっていうのを話したいと思います
それをじっ
端的に見せるのがこの写真です
45年前 papua new 次元山田
独立前夜私は市場調査のために
パパに行きに行きましたそこでコミュね山岳少数民族に出会ったんですね
私はすごく親近感を覚えましたでもちょっと
私自身が若かったから目のやり場に実は困ったんですけどね
ではなぜこんなことをやろうと思ったか
自分の背景を3つ説明したいと思います
なぜボランティアカスをやろうと思った彼の原点は私が5歳の時に受けた
自身の曲です私がまだ5歳のとき吹く日の大地震が起きて家の街が震源地だったんです
ね
すぐ上の兄と二人家の中に行ったら子連れ愚者とスフレて私たちは家の
木崎になりましたでも奇跡的に助かったんですね
で高校時代直中学校時代まさに多情多感なツギアニキっと約束しました
俺たちが助かったのが神様が何かしろって言うし妙プラサットに違いないと将来人の
ためになる人間だろうなと何度も誓い合いました
そして兄貴は医者になったんですね
私は消費者ま悪徳正面じゃないですよ
一所懸命真面目なしょう者なんだけど直接しとるためになってるっていう自信がなかっ
たいつかやりたいなっていう気持ちはずっと持ったんですね
これが潜在的な私の同期です
3,800人知りました雨家の近くまで来は6広がりました
でも助かったんですね
第二番目はなぜかというと
私は秒針がせいぜいだシティ先生だったし
一番上の兄キュアでも先生冊ですねだから教育に関心がありました
それからたまたまですが私の息子たち3人が小学校時代いじめだったんですね
何か私自信も
夫婦のためにできないかなっていう気持ちがあったこれは2つ目の理由ですね
3つ目は実は17年前
妻が亡くなりました
4年間の
看病がくなっちゃうぜ闘病の後亡くなったんですね
元だったんです
私56歳の時ですね
じゃあぞの時に私は実は
乳がんを初話をした月
実は私が海外支配人の辞令が出たんですね
だけども私はそれをねつまりも家族にを一切言わずにことがあってね
幹部生活を続けたんですしかしソヌあっ妻が亡くなった
それこそ私は落ち込みましたよ
幼稚込んだ時そうだそれたっただよし息子たちが技術して社会人になったら兄貴と約束
した世のため人のためになろう
これはもう一つの60歳で1歳のサラリーマン生活をやめてを寮費始めた理由であり
ます
それから
2004年6月私は自分の家を事務所にしてアジア教育友好は小屋協会を立ち上げまし
た
それを立ち上げたらね1年3651万円日忙しくて忙しくてね
猛烈サラリーマンが猛烈 npo ぬ間になりました
しかし私としてはねぇ
自分でいかなきゃいけない自分でね現地を調べ
本当のニーズを調べよう
それから
比例してくださる一つは近在する結果責任を負わなきゃいけないんだから自分で私は山
の中に入ったんですね
入った回数も鍵が出張する72回
訪れたものの数はおそらく400を超えています
いいね一箇所に二度も三度も入ってますからおそらく800からから1000回ぐらい
行っているってことする村に
行く側の土地は混乱パーツですよあるいは
いっても同票なっていったみんなと一緒にスコップで道路制す
ねっ
雨季に行くとねっ電子対話という限りなく
何キロも続く水の道です
g 人と話ししてねだけ飲み過ぎて上もう
尊重さんがお前本気たが前は守る娘た
名誉村民だって言ってくれたと思います食べさせないというのはこんな素晴らしいおい
ねぇ蛇んは大麻自体ハチノコの大ましたよ
ねぇそういう中で
たどり着いた胸がどんなんですよか
まさに桃源郷です
ねっ
ゆっくりとした時間が流れていて平和と隣人愛に溢れています
でも一方において
極端になるね貧困と
無知があるんですねみてください案内や魚タバコ吸ってるんですよね
あるいは村主と8割9割は一切文字が書けない
あるいは
15歳でも子供を持っていましたん
水道もガスも電気も何
ね医者も薬もないだからチーズちょっとした病気で子供が死んじゃいます
じゃあどんな学校があったのでしょうか
浦賀人たちが作ったこういう額は起こら大きく良い方です
こういうまさに壁もなく仕切りもない
こういう学校人みんな勉強してるんですあるいはこんな小さな学校で
7になって勉強しているんです頂部の1本に先に集まる子どもたちうち整体した分です
本当に勉強したいという気持ちが溢れてました
でも部屋な足りなくて床下で勉強している
あるいはついに学校が壊れてしまって炊き上げの竹やぶ学校で勉強している
こういった子がたくさんいました
でもですね
子どもたちの人々て素晴らしいんですね素晴らしいま
1日から放射される命のなんか官役っていうのが私は圧倒されました
この子たちを助けたいと同時にねこの子たちの素晴らしい上の考え機を日本の子供たち
に伝えたいと思いました
じゃあ一体どうしたら私ばね心のこもった長続きをする
建設ポロリ含んで着るのかと思って考えたのが3そうです
学校迎接し村人が参加することによって
育て見守り
出来上がった後今度は日本の子どもたちと国際交流をさせる
こういう考え方で始めました
だから最初に村に行くと私は村主つたちと話し合います裏面受注会です
最初の頃は当事者しか出てこなかったんですねの某お父さんであったんです
子供のこと本当に思うのは女性なんですよね女性と話し合いまして一体どうすれば
リンレンが出来上がるかこう否定月はなったのが
ファッション
アクションドネーションですねまず子どもたちのために何とかしたいっていう
パッションもあるんですが同列があるんですかということを話し合います
そしたらやりほしいじゃああなたせし何するんですか
黙って体立つだけではダメですよ
自分たちは山から木に乗って苦労か分から育って黒ジャージ沿ってくる
自分なじゃあ手伝うってこういう話をするんですね
オラが村の卵学校なんです子どもたちはお父さんお母さん村の人たちが手伝うも見てね
自分たちをの学校大切しますね
ある無駄で小学校をつくった時この小学校よっしゃよっしゃって村んですね web に
でし据えて担いで隣にしてこれを中学校に使いました
ねっ
ねえ
3年後今度はこれをさらにを超え植えてこれを高等学校にして
後に中学を作りましたそして去年はついに公動画を作りました
10年かかりましたけど焼酎コールの一環高校
後者っていうのをねさんに
なんて言うんですかな
校舎酒作ったんではね駄目なんですよねやっぱり
仏作って魂入れずじゃいけない
そういう守り育ち実は持つことやってわたしたちの学校の卒業生を批判学校行って先生
にしました
これ彼等は自分達の村井戻って先生になりました
自分たちの村の言葉しか喋れない子供堆肥にとって村の先生ができるって大変なことな
んですね
こうして私たちは
様子いっ
蛍雪の一つのモジュールを作ったんですねさて問題は小さいほう龍です
国際交流は日本の子ども達日本の小学校と姉妹提携を結んで日本の子どもたちの手紙と
か
作品とかを届けます
そしてその様子を
学校いってね前授業したりします願い事業の回数はもうこれまで600回を超えました
そして子どもたちに伝えることなんでよかっ
子供だアジアのや孫の子どもたちの生きる作ましたですね
必死になってその性質を大臣し親は大成する主生成をに操業する
そういうことも達の話をすると子どもたちが気づくんですね
桑ノフを聞いた先生はね
お願いだからかんっね保護者が来る日に授業してください
お母さんたちをどうさん達が一緒に聴いてくれますそのように帰ったよがである
この房たちとの金取る話し合いがすごくすんなって言うんですね
どんな話をするか
アジアの子供たちは音を弟の面倒見る4
病てねっ
獣を取るよ自分たちの絵練った企業い自分が撮ってくれよみんな仲良くやってるんだ
よっ
そうすると
そして子供たちはじゃあ何か手伝いたいと言ってあまたノートとか鉛筆をね
ぎゅーしてくれたりします
そんなこともたちの発展の段階を見て私はある提案をしました
昔アジアの子どもたちといったとアジアの雄
友達と言い出したんですね jaf の友達に対してあぁたちの積極的な義務所
何か形にしようと言って子供たちだけのお金でつくる学校を提案したのですねこれを
ワンコインスクール500円1人500円うつ病って子供たちだけの資金で学校を
つくりまし
ん
その代わりねキューブするからおばあちゃん500円頂戴窮鼠8日にを受け付けないよ
と子供さん達にアジアの子どもたちと同じように何かしなさいとなんか頑張りなさい
いや今日はお手伝いを手伝いましたあるいは今日は
をやり後輩を面倒みたあるいは小さい部は毎日の六重奏響我慢しただからそうちゃんお
試しダサい
これはねそういうがんばりカードを運動してですねこれまで我々は
生姜2ある小学校中学校単価と一緒にラックをつくってきたんですね
これまで国をつくりました
東日本代表されるとき怒ったことは
我々が作ったね学校の子どもたちがねそれを聞いて募金してくれたんですね
1年の著あのをこそががたった30円の子
必死になってその10円持ってるんですねあるいはお金がない人が
盾は
鶏もできる先生さんからにわたるって言っ
ねっ
私はたまたま
持っていったらこいのぼりね子どもたちにみんなで応援のメッセージ書いてってね
メッセージ回当時ラオスもべたのもあったので10校の学校の子供たちに応援の
メッセージを書いてもらいました
そしてこれを
二章保険に続けました
そしたらね福島県いわき市の子供たち中学生ちょうど1番に入るんですね
彼らが僕たちがあんたたちに社会というサーバになっていたどぅ団地でなんかやろ
入ってるワンコインスクールをやったんですねむ2013年大郎山奥に10万超え祝
書作りましたこういう具合にですねまさに
ん
交流事業は日本の賦存たちこそねっ
力になっている勉強になっている我々の学校建設はアジアの子どもたちのためでもあり
日本の子どもたちのためであるということを実感しています
我々のプロジェクトのねある意味は完成形がアイファースタイルの完成形がこれです私
の夢としてはですねこの愛ファーストモデルをですね
日本スタンダードにしたいなっていうのは私の夢でありね
早く300個作りたいなというのがもう一つの夢です
こんな活動してますね昔聞いた母からの言葉を思い出します
まああの震災の後正6人の子供を背負った文は一貧乏でした
でもそういう貧乏なかなかですね青谷がピン女の人を助けるのよく b てたんですね
ある日は目やにきた
上りのおばあちゃんにね王室の中に残ってたご飯を全部おにぎりにしておばあちゃんに
あげさんですね
ございそれ見てねカチャ1の母に抗議するんですね母ちゃんと内田ってこんなに貧乏
ドルに通して要素の一助ける乗って僕だってを長すぎてみろ
を講義しました
6月の母の言葉がわたしにとっては
心の柱になっていますそれは
ぜひとか思いやるっていうのが不思議な魔法の香水なんだと
純粋な気持ち無力な気持ちで人に振りかければプリかけるほどその5分は自分も
降りかかってくるものなんだよとそういう不思議な魔法の香水なんだよと
今私はですねアジアの子供たち日本の子ども達を助けるものを助けながらね
まさに感動喜びねっ
となって私のに3いっぱいすごくコーシーは降りかかっております
この更新をね私は今後ね大事に大事にしながら日本の子どもたちのためアジアなくとも
たちのために
学校建設を進めていきたいと思いますし皆さんおですね
やっぱりどこかでねっ
近くにいるお友達なんかにねこの魔法の香水を
かけ the いかがでしょうかねそれを私としては望みながら
少しは少しはしょりすぎましたけどもね私のお話しさせていただきます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]